2022 c'est le 50e anniversaire d'une
voiture mythique la renault 5 en janvier
1972 présentation de la petite nouvelle
au journal télé regardez-la se pavaner
sur les plages bretonnes la renault 5
d'une voiture compacte
longue de 3 mètres 50 proposés en deux
portes et un hayon arrière on voit là
une voiture qui a marqué les français à
l'époque et encore aujourd'hui simple
pratique modulable la nouvelle pépite de
renault est avant tout destiné aux
citadins c'est une voiture qui consomme
moins de six grosses sommes et qui
est vous le disiez vous avez raison et
une se conduit comme la commune bicycle
quatre manières et c'est surtout un
carton dès 1974 et jusqu'en 1983 elle
est la voiture la plus vendue en france
preuve de son succès la renault 5 aux
couleurs pimpantes et déclinée en
plusieurs modèles il en faut pour tout
le monde après l'a5 elle l'a 5 t elle la
5 ts et la 5 gt elle voici la renault 5
alpine le petit monstre de l'ariège
tenez la renault 5 alpine par exemple
plus puissante que sa grande soeur elle
est sortie en 1976 si vous aimez les
sportives elle est faite pour vous
vitesse de pointe 175 kilomètres/heure
une voiture qui cherche à séduire les
vrais sportifs et puis aussi les
amateurs d'accélération est aisé qui
jusqu'à présent avait fixé leur choix
sur des modèles étrangers après l'alpine
une nouvelle version voit le jour quatre
ans plus tard en 1981 c'est la renault 5
turbo
ce poids plume de 900 kg a une carrure
de leveurs de fonte qui lui donne l'air
de sortir d'une bande dessinée c'est
super cas à bord deux places seulement
mais le plaisir de dompter par yb est ce
ça vaut mieux en égoïste elle aussi en a
sous le capot elle est encore plus
rapide une pointe à 2 110 km/heure tout
de même parfait pour les courses de
rallye à l'intérieur on se croirait dans
un décor de film futuriste et ça laisse
perplexe certains journalistes à bord
des stylistes ont pris le pas sur les
techniciens pas moins de dix cadran mais
ils sont à peine lisibles et l'agente
anguleuses du volant est très
désagréable
d'autres modèles suivront mais en 1984
clap de fin pour la renault 5 l'origine
la production s'arrête la supercinq la
remplace en 2024 la marque au losange va
faire revivre la renault 5 un modèle
100% électrique
[Musique]